now our guest of honor is a favorite
person of mine and I'm cranky with him
he comes from Wisconsin you can see his
character in the fact that not long ago
friends of mine asked me to intervene
with him because I was going to be
talking with him to get him to give a
speech and I said these guys really want
you to give a speech better go give this
speech and he said you know it's deer
hunting season I've never missed that
and my response was oh ok that's a good
cause he's doing it I think he's like
that he's a father of three he comes
from a little town in Wisconsin his
career is he went to Muhammad Miami of
Ohio a college in Ohio arrival by the
way to be the second best college in the
Michigan Ohio area and I've never looked
at his grades but i but i could find
them i don't know people got into our
college or not but if he had he know
more he worked for a jack kemp and Bill
Bennett their buddies with check the
late Jack happened bill bennett and here
still good buddies he learned a lot from
them he worked for brown bag he got
elected to congress in 1998 nobody would
he they're just two things to know about
what is what he's done and the other is
what he is and I I might know what that
second thing is I know I know what he's
done if it's true that we're in a
position where the liberal society may
be about to disappear and if it's true
that the sensitive point is in the in
scale and scope and nature of the
relations between the people and the
government then what one would have to
understand
and no inside and out would be the way
that this federal budget works and that
is surely the most boring and hideous
subject in human history except it now
it's also a dangerous subject so it's
not boring anymore and the person who
learns about it first of all he's going
to have to have a heck of a mind to be
able to know about it but then second of
all he's going to have to have courage
to speak the truth about it because to
speak the truth about it is to call for
things to be reduced that have large
constituencies in favor of them and so
that's why so many don't even talk about
that subject and this man has made
himself the master of it but annoys as
no one I have ever seen why did he do
that I think it's his character he's a
good listener he's very well-spoken
things come easy to him and yet he
doesn't seem to become arrogant he loves
his children thinks he's working for
them refused to run for president
because he's foolish went to the wrong
college but I was one of those who urged
him to do that and I did that because
because of the right reason I don't know
if he could win I don't I know he's the
right kind and I know when he talks the
people get what they've got coming to
them which is the truth and a chance to
choose about it welcome speaker of the
truth
no pressure okay well thank you very
much Larry like I said no pressure there
what do you say thank you for that kind
introduction I I really appreciate that
you've been a true friend of liberty and
to me as well it's always a pleasure for
me to speak here to Hillsdale folks the
mission you have here at the kirby
center in washington is a great example
of what Hillsdale is all about in the
words James Madison liberty and learning
each leaning on the other for their
mutual insurance support in addition to
those of you who are here with us today
I'm told that these remarks are being
broadcast by webcast to the benefit of
Hillsdale students back in Michigan
where right now it's about eight thirty
in the morning or the most college
students the crack of dawn so your
scholarly passion for human freedom must
be powerful indeed this Saturday we
celebrate the two hundred and twenty
fourth anniversary or birthday of the
constitution written by the framers in
Philadelphia and paying tribute to this
inspired document I want to talk about
how we should think about the
Constitution and why especially today
this matters usually our defense of the
Constitution is presented as a defense
of Americans founding principles and our
values in rightfully so but our
constitutional system is not just a
collection of principles it embodies an
approach to government with profound
practical implications for both our
freedom and our prosperity when that
system is threatened both freedom and
prosperity suffer freedom is lost by
degrees and the deepest erosions usually
take place during times of economic
hardship when those who favor of
spending the sphere of government abuse
a crisis to persuade free citizens that
they should trade in a little of their
liberty for empty promises of greater
security well we all remember what
Benjamin Franklin said about that trade
that those who would make it deserve
neither liberty nor security but in such
cases
when liberty is lost it is our fault as
champions of the Constitution for
failing to mount a sufficiently
persuasive and effective defense and I
believe our defense falls short when we
fail to connect our timeless principles
and values to the urgent economic issues
facing the factory worker in Janesville
Wisconsin who's suddenly unable to
provide for his family or in some of
your cases the recent college graduate
who finds herself in one of the worst
job markets in recent history we can
strengthen our defense of Liberty if we
remember to keep in mind those who are
struggling to make ends meet what makes
our Constitution such an extraordinary
document is that in making the United
States the freest civilization in
history the founders guaranteed that it
would become the most prosperous as well
the American system of limited
government low taxes sound money in the
rule of law has done more to help the
poor than any other economic system ever
designed I want to talk today in
particular about the last of those the
rule of law which is absolutely
essential to all other benefits of our
system to the prosperity and freedom of
our country and to the well-being of all
Americans especially the most vulnerable
well what is the rule of law Larry just
talked about it when the Declaration of
Independence cited as justification of
the laws of nature and nature's God the
founders were channeling Aristotle who
wrote that the rule of law and principle
means that quote God and intimate alone
rule eral Aristotle defined the law as
intellect without appetite by what she
meant just as untainted by the
self-interest of those in power the
great difficulty we encounter in
striving to meet Aristotle's idea was
best summed up I think by james madison
if men were angels no government would
be necessary and if angels were to
govern men neither external nor internal
controls on government would be
necessary but as Madison remind us
men are no angels and the government is
administered by men over men grounded in
a proper understanding of human nature
our founders tackled this challenge
head-on with a brilliant constitution
and a healthy separation of powers
binding all men to the same set of laws
in preventing anyone man or group of men
from gaining enough power to declare
themselves above the law the
Constitution secures rights long
understood to be essential to the rule
of law such as the right to due process
meaning that the laws of the land must
be transparent consistent and equally
apply to all men so that no man may be
arbitrarily deprived of life liberty and
property this constitutional cornerstone
of our free society is also a critical
precondition to a free and dynamic
society in economy without the rule of
law to safeguard the ownership of
property and the enforcement of
contracts it makes little sense for an
investor to put his capital at risk
helping an entrepreneur to pursue a
dream to advance an idea and ultimately
grow a business that creates good-paying
jobs for Americans for decades the US
economy has been a magnet for investors
entrepreneurs and workers because we
enjoy some of the strongest and most
transparent legal protections in the
world these protection provide a stable
environment for business investment
stability that is totally undermined
when the discretionary power of
bureaucrats is enhanced many countries
around the world are remained mired in
grinding poverty for lack of the
institution's necessary to guard
property and contracts from the
appetites of local despots and their
cronies their economies are highly
unstable and the fate of the business
investment is often subject to the whims
of a single person or a small group of
bureaucrats the good news is that the
United States still a Joy's in enormous
edge over most of the world when it
comes to the strength of our
institutions and a reputation for
respecting the rule of law but we are
moving in the wrong direction
and we would be fool to believe that the
job treaters of this country have not
noticed that let me give you just a few
examples of how the rule of law in this
country has been degraded over the past
several years and replaced by the rule
of man the first monetary policy I'm not
suggesting that the Federal Reserve is
there anything illegal treacherous or
even treasonous but I do believe that
Congress has delegated far too much
arbitrary authority to the Fed and that
in recent years the Fed has trended too
far toward discretionary and away from
rules based monetary actions small
changes in monetary policy can have
really big economic consequences and the
central bank can serve is a major source
of economic instability in 1993 Stanford
economist John Taylor developed a rule
to improve the stability and
predictability of us monetary policy an
untold economic success story in the
1990s is the feds adherence to price
stability faced a large part to John
Taylor's key insights unfortunately the
Federal Reserve abandoned the so-called
Taylor rule roughly a decade ago after
the tuck after the tech bubble collapsed
and a growing body of evidence supports
the idea that the Fed kept interest
rates too low for too long throughout
the past decade helping to fuel the
enormous housing bubble that caused the
financial crisis of 2008 the central
bank continues to pursue a misguided
policy of arbitrary decision making that
is contributing to economic uncertainty
and in my opinion causing more harm than
good next energy in an environmental
policy I think the Obama
administration's actions here offer a
perfect example of what happens when you
concentrate too much discretionary power
into the hands of unaccountable
bureaucrats
remember in 2007 a wrongheaded Supreme
Court decision cleared the way for the
Environmental Protection Agency to
unilaterally regulate greenhouse gases
if the agency found that such gases may
reasonably be anticipated to endanger
public health or welfare as soon as the
EPA's chief from up the Obama
administration took office reasonably
was unreasonably defined and the agency
issued finding after finding that would
produce real economic harm in exchange
for distance in dubious environmental
lands well with Nancy Pelosi and Harry
Reid then running Congress the
administration first push for
legislation resembling the European
Union's cap-and-trade system because of
the EPA's power grab affected industries
face the old good cop bad cop routine it
was either play ball or closely or else
the EPA could be counted upon to come up
with something even worse given the
options it's no surprise that a who's
who of big corporations lined up to
support their bill once their priorities
were met even though most Americans
remain strongly opposed to this
legislation this bill passed the house
but it was unable to overcome bipartisan
concerns in the Senate cap-and-trade
legislation was Dean costly economically
harmful and ineffective in its means and
its goals but instead of accepting this
verdict on its preferred policy the
administration decided to let the EPA
carry on with a harmful plan to impose
unilateral emissions restrictions on
American businesses which raises the
question why does the Constitution
establish a lawmaking body at all while
the EPA has been busy pushing
commercially competitive punishing
commercially competitive sources of
energy the Department of Energy under
President Obama's direction has been
acting like the world's worst venture
capital fund
picking winners and losers mostly losers
these days by spending recklessly on
uncompetitive alternatives for evidence
look no further than solyndra a solar
panel company that recently received
five hundred million dollars in stimulus
funded loan guarantees last month
solyndra filed for bankruptcy and laid
off its employees and the story just
keeps getting worse by the day the
federal government's job is to make and
enforce sensible rules of the road so
that markets are fair transparent and
competitive when bureaucracy is
empowered to reward politically
well-connected firms at the expense of
economically competitive ones this
weekend is the rule of law it wastes
taxpayer dollars and it makes
sustainable job creation that much
harder to achieve another example we
have seen a lot of damaging economic
adventurism in the area of financial
services lately tarp was supposed to be
confined to a narrow emergency and used
to avoid precisely the kind of situation
I described at the beginning of this
speech an economic calamity in which
politicians promising security in return
for loss of freedom would do enormous
damage to the cause of Liberty needless
to say it was disappointing when the
Bush administration approved the use of
tarp funds for the bailouts of General
Motors and Chrysler this entrenched the
idea that tarp could be used as a slush
fund for just about any kind of economic
intervention regardless of the fact that
the original bill charged the program to
quote purchases troubled assets from any
financial institution that was bad but
the greater damage came later when the
Obama administration used that bailout
to trample the rights of Chrysler's
secured bond holders including state
pension funds in order to give
politically favorite groups a better
deal than they were entitled to receive
under the bankruptcy law this makes it
less likely that institutions
safeguarded in charge of safeguarding
people's life savings will invest that
money in ways that create jobs and
United
the dodd-frank overhaul made financial
services matters that much worse
dodd-frank involves radical changes to
financial regulation changes that will
affect every feature of our financial
services industry increase the power of
current federal regulatory agencies
increase new ones for example the FDIC
may now take control of any financial
institution if a panel of regulators
under the Treasury secretary see the
danger of systemic risk which is up to
the regulators to define moreover
smaller institutions do not receive the
protections given to big firms under
this law that results in unequal
treatment as well as higher borrowing
costs compared to their larger
competitors dodd-frank promotes the rule
of bureaucrats to our economic detriment
inviting political corruption while
further degrading self-government the
next case involves a troubling overreach
which I'm going to have the pleasure of
voting on in about a half-hour that
we've seen from this administration's
appointees to the National Labor
Relations Board the most notorious case
involves Boeing which the NLRB is suing
over his decision to locate a new
factory in South Carolina instead of
Union friendly Washington State's the
board's actions are threatening hundreds
of jobs but this isn't the only example
of the board's overreach early in his
administration the president promised
labor leaders that he would work to pass
a card check bill to make union
organizing easier but just like
cap-and-trade car check failed in
Congress so the NLRB's simply issued new
union election rules that would in the
words of one former board member quote
achieve the primary objectives of cards
checked by administrative rule without
the need for top congressional votes
unquote again with agencies like this
what do you need Congress for more
generally speaking we should not be
surprised to find organized labor
leading the charge for more bureaucratic
discretion and federal rulemaking an
agency that is free to broadly interpret
it statutory authority is one that can
you
laterally broaden its size and scope and
in the process it can increase the size
and influence of the public sector
unions to which its employees belong
last case the president's health care
law this one's a doozy let me share with
you a figure that serves as a
devastating indictment of the new law so
far over 1,400 businesses and
organizations have been granted
temporary waivers from the laws honoris
mandates these waivers do not guarantee
relief in the future which is that why I
like to refer to them as stays of
execution nor do they help the firm that
lack the connections to lobby for the
waivers the powerful discretion assumed
by HHS to play judge in determining
these days of execution does tremendous
damage to the rule of law the
president's health care overhaul
undermines the rule of law and so many
other ways as well the new law empowers
a panel of 15 unelected unaccountable
bureaucrats in Washington to cut
Medicare in ways that will deny benefits
for current seniors the new boards
recommendations would become law unless
a super majority voted affirmatively to
replace these recommendations a high
hurdle that raises constitutional
questions about whether Congress can
legitimately grant this much lawmaking
Authority to an unelected agency look
I'm not trying to question the
intentions of those who have decided to
make Medicare spending less accountable
to the democratic process I think they
truly believe that it is better to let
government appointed experts make these
kinds of decisions free from the checks
and balances that defined our messy
democratic process but in weakening the
rule of law in the United States their
intentions are totally irrelevant the
damage they have done is real and the
relevant question we have to ask
ourselves is whether is Ronald Reagan
put it we believe in our capacity for
self-government or whether we abandon
the American Revolution and confess that
a little intellectual elite in a far
distant capital can plan our lives
better for us than we can plan them are
sells if we succumb to this view that
our problems are bigger than we are if
we surrender more control over our
economy to the governing class then life
in America will become defined by a new
kind of class warfare a class of
bureaucrats and connected crony
capitalists trying to rise above the
rest of us call the shots rigged the
rules and preserve their place atop
society and their guineans come at the
expense of working Americans
entrepreneurs and that small
businesswoman who has the gall to take
on the corporate chieftain the
Constitution's framers knew that there
is a human inclination to increase
personal power at the expense of law so
they created a congress as decentralized
in an internally divided institution but
they granted at ample authority to
secure the rule of law in every case
Congress holds the power of the pen as
well as the power of the purse it had
the power necessary to address the
attacks on the rule of law in our
executive bureaucracies and even in the
courts the Constitution provides us with
the power to solve these problems what
we need is the will to do it the
solution the defense of the rule of law
will have to involve alternative ways to
address the public problems that too
many of our friends on the left want to
solve by simply delegating power to
bureaucrats for every government
curtailment of our Liberty for the
discretion of bureaucrats there are
alternative reforms that could address
these same problems within the framework
of the rule of law and indeed they could
address these problems more effectively
House Republicans have proposed a policy
agenda to do just that reclaiming
America's exceptional promise charting a
path not only toward fiscal
sustainability but also to renewed
prosperity restoring the rule of law
reducing the influence of bureaucrats
and the lives of Americans and
empowering them to take more control
over their own lives is central to the
budget we passed earlier this year in
fact such reforms go hand-in-hand
our efforts to lift the crushing burden
of debt to secure our social safety net
and to spur job creation and sustained
economic growth for all Americans in
monetary policy Congress must refocus
the Federal Reserve on price stability
within a clear rules based system
because businesses and Families alike
needs sound money to invest to grow into
prosper in energy Congress must limit
the EPA's discretionary power to impose
a unilateral vision of a job destroying
cap-and-trade system in financial
services Congress needs to establish a
regulatory environment that is fair
predictable and reasonable in labor
policy Congress needs to rein in an
agency that is starting job creation by
overreaching its mandate and to make
sure that we have a public sector that
works for the people that serves and not
the other way around and in health care
we just need to repeal the president's
do disastrous health care law
that way we will diminish the power of
unelected bureaucrats over the system
and give that power to individuals and
families by advancing reforms that
harness the power of choice and
competition in health care rather than
increasing the size and scope of central
administration let us champion an agenda
guided by the American idea of equal
rights under law let's begin to remove
the hurdles that government has erected
legislative reform short of power people
families in computers and communities
season not bureaucrats and their cronies
the American idea unites Liberty and law
in a bond that must never be severed
America can win back the promise of
individual liberty a promise we have and
we have continued to shed blood to
defend but the time has come to honor
our constitutions limits on arbitrary
bureaucracy and return to the rule of
law to make it the center of our
government now look looking out here on
the faces today and knowing that some of
you woke up at the crack of dawn at
830am to watch online I am hopeful I am
confident and optimistic because of
Hillsdale and others that a new
generation is coming to the study of
politics with a real appreciation to the
Constitution and its centrality to
ensuring justice and security in our
communities to promoting the welfare and
prosperity of all people and to securing
the blessings of liberty to ourselves
and for our children by respecting the
rule of law reclaiming the prominence of
our Constitution and reforming our
government I have no doubt that we the
people working together can help ensure
that the next generation of citizens
inherence a stronger freer more
prosperous America and a more perfect
union thank you very much for having me
today
thank you
thank you very much
I thank you I apologize i intended to
stay and do QA but a boat is being
called to rein in the NLRB and to swear
in two new members of Congress and i
don't want to miss those two events all
right but thank you very much I
appreciate it thank you